Columbia is one of the richest countries
in terms in terms of biodiversity and we
are also one of the most vulnerable
countries in terms of climate change
that gives us a special responsibility
and we need to protect as soon as
possible
the largest amount of territories that
are the jewel for Colombians and for
Humanity and that's why I guard geared
up towards accelerating the process of
protecting the most valuable resources
you have what are the richness that
Colombia has is not only marvelous
biodiversity of found and flora but also
our ethnic diversity we have many
indigenous communities and we call them
our older brothers and what they say to
us younger brothers is please protect
the most important thing you have mother
earth when I took over the presidency he
said take care of Mother Earth because
she is mad and she was mad we have
suffered the worst natural disasters in
Colombia in our history and anybody who
doesn't see that is really I would say
myopic they don't see the reality
[Music]
after every peace process there's a
backlash and there's leftovers of the
war and they have to be taken care of
Columbia has had a dramatic change for
the best in the last few decades last
years we now have peace after 53 years
of war this is a very very important
change for a country that has been
devastated by war but there's one
priority that we need to address which
is the demining Colombia still the
second most mined country in the whole
world after Afghanistan and if we want
to be able to enjoy peace we need to
demine the country I would say that's
priority number one but of course the
restitution of land to the peasants
which were already doing is also a
priority
the sustainable way of developing these
areas that were simply left over because
of the war is also another priority for
people to see change as soon as possible
this is a big challenge that we have now
of the post-conflict other resources
that are in a way liberated because
they're not concentrated in waging the
war are now being used to protect these
areas in a responsible way in a
sustainable way in order to develop the
areas protect the areas and especially
avoid the damage that some people are
doing we are the richest country for
example in the species of birds we are a
paradise for bird watchers we are a
country with tremendous ethnic diversity
a country that is
looking to the future with great
optimism but it's so evident that we are
destroying Mother Earth it's so evident
that the climate change is a reality we
need to encourage everybody because this
is not the problem of one country or a
few countries is a problem of mankind
and we must all all be aware that we
need to coordinate and work together and
stop climate change otherwise our future
generations will simply disappear
[Music]
and so anybody who doesn't know about
Colombia the only risk is that you might
want to stay there
[Music]